journée découverte au campus de
formation Paul Cézanne au programme
visite des lieux et rencontre avec les
formateurs ce nouvel établissement
propose de multiples formations en
s'adressant en priorité aux jeunes
décrocheurs et aux demandeurs d'emploi
aujourd'hui 14 structures sont installés
donc à la fois de la formation
qualifiante et aussi de la formation
diplômante donc vous avez aussi bien un
service à la personne que de
l'informatique que du BTP et aussi tout
ce qui tourne autour de l'animation
l'objectif formé des jeunes de tous
horizons en seulement quelques semaines
en reprenant les bases je leur montre
comment comment fixer un lavabo comment
comment brancher une prise comment
comment carreler comment faire de la
peinture vraiment les bébés du métier
quoi alors là on a des compétences qui
sont des compétences techniques et à la
couleur à la technique en coiffure à la
permanente à des choses très techniques
et qui se font en salon et puis aussi
des compétences pratiques qui sont liées
à la coupe qui sont liées au barberies
ce format apprentissage séduit de plus
en plus alors que de nombreux jeunes
peinent à s'intégrer dans un parcours
scolaire classique il y a
un certain rejet du système éducatif tel
qu'il existe traditionnellement donc ils
veulent des choses qui soient le moins
théorique possible le plus court
possible et donc surtout il soit certain
parce qu'ils ont trop vu le système
d'impasse que ça débouche sur un emploi
l'initiative plaît et donne de l'espoir
à de nombreux habitants du quartier ça
permet de sortir les jeunes dans leurs
difficultés de les former et de le
mettre dans un système pour leur avenir
futur depuis son ouverture à la rentrée
2022 le campus a déjà permis la
formation de plus de 750 jeunes